BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 1: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
All right.
Hey, Google Developers.
Welcome to The Michael
and Ryan Show.
I'm Michael Manoochehri.
RYAN BOYD: And I'm Ryan Boyd.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And we're
here to talk about some new
features of Google BigQuery
as well as answer
some of your questions.
So if you have some questions
for us, visit us at our Google
Developers Live page--
that's
developers.google.com/live--
and leave your question on
the Moderator link below.
RYAN BOYD: And if you're seeing
a recording of this
later, you can feel
free to ask your
questions on Stack Overflow.
Michael was just answering
some questions here--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
As I always am.
RYAN BOYD: --as we were
preparing, so--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Use the
Google-BigQuery tag for that.
Great.
So if you've been following
our recent Google BigQuery
blog posts, you know the theme
for this week is making
BigQuery more flexible.
So today we're going to start
by talking about some new
features that we've just
recently launched to help make
BigQuery more flexible.
The first is the batch
processing for BigQuery, which
allows a more flexible pricing
model for your queries.
And the second is the Google
BigQuery connector for Excel,
which will allow you to use it
in a more flexible environment
such as spreadsheets.
So we'll talk about
that later.
So let's talk about the batch
processing for Google BigQuery.
So, you know, Google BigQuery
is great for interactive
queries, so queries over
large data sets
that return very fast.
We found some customers using
Google BigQuery for batch
processing as well, so queries
run overnight, queries that
cache data for later use,
where interactivity is
not the main goal.
So we've introduced a new
feature for this use case at a
much reduced price, which
is Google BigQuery Batch
Processing.
This allows you to set the
priority of a query to batch
mode, which allows the
query to run later.
So the query will be run
somewhere between 30 minutes
and three hours after you
actually insert the query at a
much reduced cost.
This is great for applications
that have a data set and
allows you to run queries either
interactively or in a
batch mode, letting you build
much better applications for
this kind of a use case.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, and it's
really easy to do.
It's a simple new property in
your JSON configuration.
You just specify the priority
mode as Batch, and our client
libraries already support
this as well.
So try it out.
And I wanted to actually stop
over to our computer here and
show you an example
of a dashboard.
This is the BIME dashboard,
which shows some retail
statistics.
And this is the type of thing
that you might want to have
some of the queries running in
batch mode while other of the
queries run in sort of an
interactive manner.
So this is a dashboard showing
the retail statistics, sales
from a retail outlet.
And a lot of different graphs
here going over--
what do we have?
Like 500,000 rows--
whoops.
Sorry for that.
But going over a large number
of rows here, but overall--
oh sorry, 500 million rows.
And we have profit and discount
per category, top
products per category, profit
in various ways.
So these types of things you
might be able to calculate on
a nightly basis in
this batch mode.
Whereas maybe if you want to
allow users to drill down on
certain bits of data, for
instance, the sales just over
the last week or something like
that, you might want to
have that running more live
against the live data set and
allow people to drill down into
particular categories or
drill down into particular
types of products
and things like that.
So this is one of those use
cases where you might want
some things in batch and really
caching those query
results and then other things
you want to perform live.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And on the
flip side, it's easy to
make an application
that's actually
doing more batch queries.
And when you need that
interactive query immediately
for a presentation or for some
kind of analysis, you can run
them when you need them.
So it really expands the types
of applications you can build
with Google BigQuery.
RYAN BOYD: Exactly.
Now, I'm going to start talking
a little bit about the
other feature that we launched,
which is the Google
BigQuery connector for Excel.
The BigQuery connector for
Excel is basically a tool
which allows you to--
let me hop over to it here.
It allows you to basically pull
in your data into Excel
from BigQuery.
So you could run queries off
of hundreds of millions or
billions of rows of data and
pull your aggregate results
down into Excel for
further analysis.
And this is very useful if
you're spending a lot of your
time running data in Excel.
We actually have had a feature
for a while now which allows
you to do this type of thing
with Google Spreadsheets, with
Google Apps Script and
Google Spreadsheets.
And I'll show you that here
quickly before we dive too
much into the Excel version.
This is a dashboard I built
using Google Spreadsheets and
Google Apps Script that
basically I can hit here.
I can run the query.
It dumps the results in from
BigQuery and then does a graph
right here within Google
Spreadsheets.
Well, we wanted to bring the
same capability to Excel
users, and we've done that with
this BigQuery connector.
You can find it at
bigquery-connector.appspot.com.
And essentially what it is, is a
proxy server for your query.
So when you run your queries
in Excel, it makes HTTP
requests to the BigQuery
connector for Excel.
And those HTTP requests then
gets translated into API calls
to the BigQuery REST API.
But it all happens seamlessly
for you as a user.
There's just a few
setup processes,
and it's really simple.
So the first thing that you need
to do here is actually
authorize the connector
for Excel.
I've already granted OAuth
permission here, but if you
haven't, you'll just
be prompted to
approve OAuth request.
And then you create this key.
And this key is a value that
you'll just need to copy and
paste into Excel.
So we going to do that
here in a second.
But the other thing
you want to do is
download this IQY file.
And the IQY file is really just
a configuration file that
tells Excel the information
that it needs in order to
query against the BigQuery
connector.
So we're going to hop over into
Excel here a second and
show you how some of
this stuff is used.
So I'm going to actually
run a query here.
The query is going to be
against the US birth
statistics data, so all the
births since 1969 in the
United States.
It's, I think, 137
million rows.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It's
a pretty big data set.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, it's
pretty big.
It's still small by BigQuery
standards, but it's a great
demonstration data set.
So I'm going to run
that query.
And I've actually templatized
that query a little bit in a
similar way to what you
could do in Excel.
And I've put in here additional
fields, average
mother age, and then I have
this full query here.
So let's show you how we
would run the query.
We're going to need a few
bits of data for setup.
But I'm going to go to the Data
menu here and say Get
External Data and say
Run Saved Query.
And then I'm going to select
that IQY file that is in my
Downloads folder.
So the IQY file is right
here, connector.iqy.
And I'm going to say Get Data.
And it's going to ask where I
want to put the data, and I
want to put the data
into a new sheet.
And I want to set up the
parameters that are required
to connect to the connector.
The parameters are the query
itself, which I'm going to get
the value from this cell.
Then the Project ID, and
the Project ID is also
pretty easy to get.
We can get that from the
BigQuery UI here.
So I have the Project ID.
It comes up in a hover, and I
can copy and paste that, and
enter in the value
in this box here.
And then the key is that
generated key that we use to
pass our authorization over to
the BigQuery connector, sort
of copy that in.
And I'm going to hit OK.
And again, we are saying
populate the data into the new
sheet, run that query.
So this query is going to get us
the state and year of every
birth, but aggregated, based off
of the average age of the
mother when the child
was born.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:And this is
doing a table scan of how
many records, did you say?
RYAN BOYD: I think it
was 137 million.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: 137
million records.
RYAN BOYD: We'll actually show
you running the query in the
BigQuery UI here a second.
You'll see some more
statistics data.
But let's make this a little
bit larger for you here.
So here's the data.
And it's basically every state
and the year, and then what
the average age of the mother's
birth in that state
in that year.
So that's really simple.
Now let's just say we wanted
to change this because I
actually want the average weight
of the babies rather
than the average age
of the mother.
So I'm going to hop over to
this first sheet here.
And I'm going to change
this to, say,
average weight pounds.
And you could, of course, get
these values, build these
values up from a--
you can build these
sorry.
It looks like we had a little
bit of a glitch
here with my sharing.
So you could build these values
up from other fields
within your Excel spreadsheet.
So--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So using
some of the features of your
Excel spreadsheet, you can
actually incorporate that into
the query that you're
running now.
RYAN BOYD: Exactly.
So I'm going to hop over here,
and I need to reshare my
presentation window.
It looks like we had a little
bit of a glitch here, but let
me do that.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So while
we're doing that-- yeah, I
think it's great that for both
of these applications with
Google Spreadsheets or Excel,
it lets you use what you're
used to for analysis with
Google BigQuery.
RYAN BOYD: So, for example, like
in there, I built up the
formula, and I just did a simple
Replace on the fields
that I was trying to substitute
in the formula.
And that was pretty easy.
But you might want to actually
do something more complicated,
where you're using the built-in
Excel functions and
accepting the analyst input
because not all analysts will
necessarily know
how to use SQL.
But as long as you can set up
this initial spreadsheet for
them with SQL, it's fairly
easy for you to do then.
And I'm hoping I can--
yeah, here we go.
So I'm going to reshare
my screen here.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: All
right, looks good.
RYAN BOYD: There we go.
I've reshared my screen,
and let's hop
back over into Excel.
Sorry about that little
glitch here.
So here's my query.
So I wanted to modify this to
say the average weight in
pounds instead of the average
mother's age.
So I've modified just this
field here quickly.
And you could specify any
the other fields that
are part of the table.
But I modified that.
And then I'm just going to go
over to the Data tab here and
just say Refresh.
And if we hop over to our sheet,
we can see we had the
mother's age when they
gave birth broken
down by year and state.
And when this refreshes here,
instead of the mother's age,
we're going to get
the birth weight.
So we'll see here-- and it's a
little small again for you, so
I'll enlarge it.
And let's see here.
So we can see that refreshed
it in really easy.
All I had to do was press one
button to refresh that
information.
That was very simple.
If you're actually using the
Windows version of Excel, you
can actually set up
dependent fields.
So you can basically say, if the
fields that were used to
build up the query change at
all, you can ask it to
automatically refresh.
So there's none of that
manual refreshing.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So that
was the same data set, the
same original 100 and something
million record data set.
You just changed one parameter
and re-run the query.
RYAN BOYD: Exactly.
And it was really easy
for us to do.
But, you know, we can run this
type of query directly in the
BigQuery UI, right?
You know, just getting this
data, and you can see
I ran it over here.
It took about seven seconds,
processed 2 and 1/2
gigabytes of data.
So that was pretty simple to
run within the BigQuery UI.
But the advantage of Excel is
the analysis that you could do
after you run the query.
So let's say that I want to take
this data and I want to
go over and do a pivot table.
So I just say Pivot Table.
And it creates the
pivot table here.
And then what I can do is,
this is just the count to
start with.
Let's just change this
to be the average
instead of the count.
And so now we can see here for
every single state, this
massive table that shows you
what the weight of the babies
were in that state broken
down by year.
But if we want to take this from
a pivot table and take it
into a chart, a chart might be
more easy for some people to
read although I don't want
to chart out every state.
So let's limit here to just
pick a few states.
So we'll pick California,
Colorado, Alaska.
Let's pick Alaska.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: That
sounds pretty good.
RYAN BOYD: And so just
a few states here.
And I don't know--
Louisiana.
And we'll pick a few
states here.
And now we're going to take this
and make it into a graph.
So I have that data, and now
let's take here, and we'll
just say Charts, and we'll
say Align Charts.
And it looks like I actually
selected a value here, so that
didn't quite work out.
So let me recreate this
here without me
having selected a value.
So we just say Line Chart.
This is going to work.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
There it is.
RYAN BOYD: All right.
There we go.
So here we have our graph.
And these are aggregate results,
but the source data
is over 100 million
rows of data.
So it's pretty fantastic.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
So with very little
SQL, actually no SQL.
No SQL is coming out.
You've actually been able to
pull all the data from
BigQuery into a pivot table and
chart it, just using what
you normally are used
to in these
spreadsheet tools like Excel.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, I mean, I did
create that initial SQL, but
for the analyst, you know, the
IT person can create the SQL
and the analyst can just
plug-in the fields that
they're interested in.
And it's really easy.
And we can then look down and
see hey, we have 7.6 or so
pounds per baby in Alaska.
But then if we go down
and see Colorado, it
looks like about 7.1.
So--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: You know
what I'm about to say.
Is that statistically
significant?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, it's not
statistically significant.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
We don't know.
RYAN BOYD: I don't know.
So you could talk to the CDC or
talk to Michael if you're
trying to figure out
whether this is--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Export your
data and run it in R. You
can do all kinds of stuff
with this data.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
So we can see here, we are able
to really easily pull in
data, run data, run huge
queries on large
data sets in BigQuery--
pull the results into Excel,
throw them into pivot tables,
throw them into graphs.
It's a really powerful
feature.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
I love this idea of using the
workflows you're used to and
using the power of
BigQuery for what
it's good at, so great.
We'd love to get your feedback
on some of these new features.
And a great way to get the
feedback to us is to join our
circle, our new Google
Cloud Platform
Developers Google+ page.
So if you search now for Google
Platform Developers in
Google+, you'll find our page.
Please add us to your circles.
You can actually comment
on our threads.
We post a lot of things that
are coming up, for example,
some new events that we're
going to be at and some
upcoming conferences.
So let's talk about
some of those.
So Ryan, can you talk about some
of the conferences you've
been to or you're going to
be at in the near future.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
I recently just did a conference
or actually a local
meetup last weekend
on Saturday.
It was a great event.
It went a lot of the
day on Saturday.
But it was a big data science
meetup, and it was in Fremont,
But at the SGI building in
Fremont, and it was fantastic.
We had three separate speakers,
and those three
speakers were myself, as well
as some folks from Zementis
and Pervasive, all talking
about some big data
technologies everywhere, from
kind of predictive modeling to
ETL to running queries using
a tool like BigQuery.
And it was a fantastic event.
The meetup has only
been going--
I think this was the sixth
session of the meetup, but
very well organized, and
they had over 60
people at the event.
So it's great to go to
these local meetups.
Let us know if you're
an organizer.
Let us know what types of
meetups you're having.
Reach out to us.
It's possible we may
be able to attend.
So that's just one
of the meetups.
But then--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
We'll definitey
see that group again.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
And coming up, we have a
couple other events.
So I think next week,
we have the--
I believe it's on the fifth--
the Google Developer Groups in
Silicon Valley, and the Google
Developer Group in Silicon
Valley is hosting myself to talk
about BigQuery and answer
questions that you have
as developers.
And fortunately, it's turned
into a rather popular event,
fortunately or unfortunately,
however you
want to look at it.
So it's fully booked, but get
on the wait list and maybe
you'll be able to get in.
But that should be great.
And then after that, the
following week we have the
XLDB Conference in Stanford.
And I'll be speaking there about
BigQuery to a group of
hardcore scientists.
So hopefully I don't disappoint
them, but--
anyway, Michael, I guess we have
some other events coming
up in the fall too, right?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I was just
about to say we're both
going to be at the upcoming
Strata conferences.
One is in London at the
beginning of October, October
first and second, and there's
a Strata Conference in New
York at the end of October.
So at Strata London,
Ryan's going to be
talking about BigQuery.
And we're going to have Kathryn
Brisbin, another one
of our teammates, talk about
data journalism and data
gathering there.
So that'll be really exciting.
We're also planning on some
community events around that
time with the London GDG group
and some other groups.
So follow our Cloud Platform
Developers page for more
information about that.
And I will be speaking
at Strata New
York along with Kathryn.
We'll also have a talk about
using BigQuery with GitHub
data, which is very exciting.
And Ryan, you have some
community events around the
time on the East
coast as well.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
So we've worked with some of
the community organizers to
plan some events over in both
Boston and New York, so local
Google developer groups in
Boston and New York, and that
should be fantastic as well.
So let us know if you have other
opportunities for us.
We're happy to look at our
travel schedule and see if we
can fit those in.
But there should be
some great events.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: We'd love
to see you guys there.
RYAN BOYD: So this has
been fantastic.
I hope you have enjoyed some of
our new features that we've
been launching in BigQuery.
Let's actually jump over.
We actually do have
some questions
over here on our Moderator.
So if you're trying to get into
the Moderator, you can
look at Google Developers Live
page, and you can click on our
event on the Google Developers
Live page if you're not
already on that page.
And you can see the
Moderator below.
And we have a couple
questions here.
The top question coming in here
is, "Could you also point
out scale-wise where you will
use BigQuery versus Google
Cloud SQL?" So we're happy
to talk about that.
Google Cloud SQL is our
MySQL-based solution that runs
in the cloud.
It's a really simple kind of
database offered as a service
that you can use from App Engine
and maybe even from
some other environments.
But basically, it's
a MySQL database.
It's a relational database.
So from a scale perspective,
it's not going to have the
same scaling properties as
something like BigQuery.
So let's just give you some
basic properties of these
different types of databases.
Your standard relational
databases use indexes to find
results quickly.
And indexes are fantastic if
what you're looking for is
available in that index.
You can get fairly
quick results.
But indexes have two properties
which aren't so
good, and one is that
it takes a while to
build up the indexes.
So as you ingest the data,
it takes a while
to build those up.
But then secondly, if you're
trying to do large-scale
aggregate data in an ad hoc
fashion, you don't necessarily
know what columns you're trying
to query against or
what sort of aggregates
you're looking for.
And the aggregates oftentimes
are kind of impossible to
really include in the indexes.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: You end
up running table scans for
some of these things, over
enormous amounts of tables
with lots of links.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
So full table scans used to be
considered kind of the devil.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
RYAN BOYD: We have this quote
from our Google I/O
presentations, one of our
colleagues, Jordan, who
basically said a quote from a
16th century French-Italian
philosopher or something like
that, where he's like, if
you're running over a full table
scan over hundreds of
millions of rows, you're going
to have a bad time.
And typically that's
how it is.
But BigQuery actually does full
table scans, and it's
designed to do full
table scans.
Pretty much every query you run
against BigQuery does a
full table scan, but since we
can distribute that over tens,
hundreds of machines around the
world, those queries can
still run really quickly even
though they're doing a full
table scan.
Each machine is only processing
a very small chunk
of data, so it allows us to do
the full table scans quickly.
So I would say use Google Cloud
SQL if you're trying to
power your web application
for just sort of--
let's say you have an online
forum or something like that
and you want to power that.
You need a lot of write
capabilities.
You need to update data.
You need to insert new data,
add and delete columns.
Cloud SQL would be really
good for that.
But if you really need to do the
performance of large-scale
analytics, that's where
BigQuery comes in.
BigQuery doesn't allow you
to modify the data.
It allows you to insert
new data.
But then you can run queries
over it much, much faster.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And I think
of it that way, too.
Cloud SQL or SQL in general is
great for transactional data,
maintaining state about
a database.
BigQuery is really great for
asking questions about large
data sets, right?
So it's really great as
an analysis tool.
It's not designed to be
a relational database.
It's designed for aggregate
queries, asking questions, and
dealing with data sizes that
are massive, that a SQL
database just can't
handle very well.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, and I mean,
typically, you actually
denormalize your data for
BigQuery just to get that
additional performance gained
by not having to scan over
multiple tables.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
And it seems like it leads well
into the next question,
which is a very similar
question.
So the question there--
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
Sorry, one second.
But I just wanted to address
with MySQL that usually you
can use these technologies
together.
So don't think of it as you have
to use one or the other.
You really think about
using them together.
And we have a lot of our
customers that dump data out
of relational databases into
BigQuery before analysis.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
So let's take a look at
the next question.
So the next question is just
what Ryan was talking about.
"Can this sit on top of a MySQL
database, and can it
replace Lucene for querying?"
So yes, I've used all these
technologies together, too.
So just as Ryan said, typically
in a workflow like
this where you're using a MySQL
database for things like
transactional data and the
kind of things you would
normally use a SQL-style
database for, you would
actually export the data into
cloud storage and then ingest
that into BigQuery.
And sometimes this does take a
denormalization step since
BigQuery is often, at times,
used for large tables rather
than relational table design.
But basically, you can
use them together.
So I would take the data out
of MySQL and place it into
BigQuery for some of these
kind of analysis tools.
Now, you mentioned Lucene
in this question.
Lucene is great for things
like searching.
It's kind of a search tool.
And App Engine has a full-text
search API
for stuff like that.
However, you can use BigQuery
for some types of search.
One thing that may be difficult
for a full-text type
search is that we have
64-kilobyte record size.
So if you have unlimited text,
it's hard to dump megabytes
into a single BigQuery record.
You can break that text up and
have an index sort of type
situation in BigQuery.
But in general, for a full-text
search kind of
application, I might use App
Engine's Full Text Search API.
BigQuery is great for things
like word counts, right?
So things like we have a
Wikipedia data set, which we
have and we're going to
have revision history.
You could do word counts, word
statistics, things like that.
That be a great use case for
BigQuery because the data in
those situations can be very big
if you have a lot of text.
RYAN BOYD: So one thing that
were actually powerful,
though, in terms of text
searching with BigQuery is our
regular expressions
capabilities.
So although the row size is a
little limited, for the text
that you do have stored in
those rows, you could run
regular expressions on it.
And you might think running
regular expressions on
hundreds of millions or billions
of rows would take a
long time, but BigQuery can
actually do that in seconds
simply because it's distributed
to such a wide
number of machines.
So try out the regular
expressions search if you're
trying to just search, for
instance, titles or abstracts
or something like that as
opposed to a full document.
BigQuery might be good for some
of those use cases with
big data sets.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And we have
that public data set in
BigQuery now, the
Ngrams data set.
So we have a selection
of Ngrams from the
Google Books project.
We can see how we've used Ngram
data as sort of a way
you can do searches.
You can search for phrases and
search for particular Ngrams.
And so check out how
we're doing that.
I guess the short answer is
you can use all of these.
These are all complementary
technologies.
And real big data workflow, you
can use them all together.
RYAN BOYD: And there's actually
one other thing we
want to talk with you about is
just kind of share a little
bit with you guys about
what we've been up to
over the last week.
So we've been having a lot of
fun over the last week,
pulling late nights.
I think I was up to 2:00 or 3:00
AM a couple times playing
with some of the Wikipedia
data that we found.
We actually found it at
dumps.wikimedia.org.
They actually have the number
of page views by hour for
every page in Wikipedia
going back for about
five years, I believe.
And so we've been crunching
along this data and trying to
use some of the other Google
Cloud technologies just to get
familiar with some of the
other Google cloud
technologies like the Pipelines
API on App Engine.
Michael, do you want to talk
a little more about that?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Yeah, sure.
So we're building a
complete pipeline.
We're extracting the data from
the Wikipedia dumps page.
We're transforming it into CSV
data, into Google cloud
storage, and we're ingesting
that into Google BigQuery
using 100% Google Cloud
Platform technologies,
basically App Engine and
the Pipelines API
to build the workflow.
So for each step, we have a
pipelines API class that we're
using to build this workflow.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, and it's--
I think it's 2 terabytes
of raw source data.
That's actually gzipped data.
We haven't uncompressed all of
it, but I'm guessing from what
we've seen, somewhere between
6 and 10 terabytes of
uncompressed data.
So it's a pretty fantastic size
of data, and it's really
great to play around with
that data in BigQuery.
Like I said, we've been having a
lot of fun, pulling a lot of
late nights.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It's been
fun, and eventually we'll
share the code from some of
these projects so you can
actually check out what
we're doing yourself.
RYAN BOYD: And I don't think
we actually have any more
questions from the audience on
our Moderator, so we'll wrap
it up for this week.
But we wanted to thank you all
for joining us and invite you
to come out to some of the
upcoming community events that
we're doing, whether you're in
the Bay Area, whether you're
in Boston, or New
York, or London.
We may actually even
be out to Sydney--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yep.
RYAN BOYD: --in the fall.
So let us know where you're
going to be and join us where
we're going to be.
We'd love to talk with you about
the big data challenges
that you're having and see
which of the Google Cloud
Platform technologies
are a good fit.
I love the questions.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Don't
forget to add to the Google
Cloud Platform Developers page
to your circle so you can find
out about all these
upcoming events.
RYAN BOYD: Great.
That's it for the Michael
and Ryan show.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
We'll see ya.
RYAN BOYD: Take care.
[MUSIC PLAYING]